the cast of bridgerton we just start
tomorrow i'm ready come on season two
can't come soon enough and e.t was first
on the london set to get all the gossip
behind the scenes
sorry lady whistle down
[Music]
this is really similar to my house at
home
as all brits do live in these sweeping
staircase halls
82 million households have watched
season one of netflix's number one
series
one reason the steamy love scenes we
rehearse everything almost like a stunt
it's lucky to have someone like reggae
that i work with who we get on really
well with
yeah they get on well alright their
chemistry is so hot some fans think
phoebe and reggae jean are a real life
couple
they're not spilling the tea but they
told us shooting this scene
was not as romantic as it looked we
learned a lot of skills on this set
including how to be a fish whilst acting
the two got married season one so for
season two can we
expect more wedded bliss i think that
one of the most important things about
the idea of the happy ending is that
it doesn't end there like love is a
continuous process it needs
tending it needs work it needs it gets
tested
and while you watch season one on
netflix we know jonathan bailey will be
looking for even
more love on season two it's gonna get
more
exciting convoluted and sexier i think
sexier are we gonna get even sexier
scenes
is that possible is it possible we'll
[Music]
try